the letter is by far the smallest
capital city in the EU just 6,500 people
live within its confines so it's not far
to today's meeting place the upper
baraka gardens a park created in the
18th century tenant Joseph Kalia is
giving an interview to The Times of
Malta newspaper in the past few years
he's grown increasingly popular
appearing in opera houses the world over
you just came back from Chicago but does
it mean to you to be here again on Malta
you know Superman right Superman gets
his energy from the Sun I have a similar
situation when I come to Malta is that I
feel that somehow even if I'm tired of
the long flight or a long series of
performances the minute I I'll and the
minute they open the door really I feel
energized again Joseph Calleja is
showing off his valletta just around the
corner is the Auberge Turkish tea which
houses the offices of the Maltese Prime
Minister it's not open to the public but
because kaleia knows the Prime Minister
this is an exclusive tour into the
letters underworld the city was built as
a fortress and there are many tunnels
connecting the buildings with each other
Joseph khilaya is also Malta's newly
appointed cultural ambassador and he's
proud of valletta the city became a
unesco world heritage site in 1980 it's
filled with buildings that dates back to
the 16th century
and this is what it's like to be seen
with a celebrity every few meters people
stop Joseph khilaya and asked for a
photo you're welcome Jay right now the
population here is six and a half
thousand how many of those people who
you actually know here no actually of
course I'm a big public figure in Malta
so many people know me and my popularity
here I love because thanks to to being
popular thanks to being in the people's
heads they automatically think they they
make my name synonymous with classical
music and with mortar and I'm
comfortable with all those the 18th
century minus L theater one of the
oldest in the world still in operation
this is where kebaya made his stage
debut in 1998 yeah brought something
with me probably you remember that
our euromaxx report from 2007 back then
we shot a whole series about Joseph
Kalia and his island country among other
things he showed us the Mediterranean
film studios in northeastern Malta and
the city of vittoriosa a rising star at
the time he had one aim to become an
even better singer than he was but would
you say you're better today than you
wear in two thousand seven percent yes
yeah yes I'm much so much on a different
level and number days both career wise
but me then it might my god it was still
extraordinary but nowadays my much more
in command of my instrument I have
measured in a much better artist and he
gives us proof of that in st. john's
co-cathedral where he points out one of
the islands major attractions the
italian painter caravaggio's masterpiece
the beheading of John the Baptist then
comes the private concert
afterwards it's on to the Grand Master's
Palace the size of an entire city block
it's the biggest building in Valletta
Joseph khilaya has also sung a concert
here for Queen Elizabeth the second
before sunset we take a tour on one of
the traditional water taxis valletta has
the world's largest natural deepwater
Harbor Joseph khilaya uses his boating
license to take a turn at the helm he's
showing us the port for a specific
reason malta must be experienced on land
of course but also by vote if you
haven't seen more for my vote
I would seem in the evening it's off to
the truck box of wine bar Joseph Kalia
comes here with friends as often as he
can and as a farewell gift one of the
best souvenirs Malta can offer a CD
signed by Joseph Kalia